du du du du du du du du du let's go
meine Adresse die wollen wir
sehen er für euch falls ihr richtiges
asmr hören wollt geht auf meinen
asmr-kanal lauschwanne asmr irgendwo
wahrscheinlich verlinkt okay wir müssen
uns über den Pamela reif Adventskalender
unterhalten bzw ihn Auspacken denn es
ist gerade ganz schön viel los um sie
herum unter anderem wurde sie auf tiktok
dafür kritisiert dass sie ihre Produkte
ja als gesünder darstellt da es mit
kokosblütenzucker gesüßt ist ich bin da
jetzt nicht ganz so in dem
wissenschaftlichen Fakten Themen drin
aber es ist auf jeden Fall so dass sie
schon Werbung damit gemacht hat dass sie
es als gesünder dargestellt hat
zumindest der Christian Wolf gesagt und
in meinem letzten Adventskalender
auspackt Video haben wir uns ja schon so
ein bisschen darüber unterhalten das ist
ja nicht erst seit gestern Thema und
deswegen bin ich dieses mal ganz
besonders gespannt wie der Kalender so
sein wird
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Adventskalender auspack Video mein
Name ist Vanessa ich werde euch heute
durch den Abend führen und diesen
Kalender mit euch auspacken und da hatte
ich schon mal ein gutes Intro happier
and health your no Cain sugar only
natural in greedians cane sugar heißt ja
Rohrzucker und Rohrzucker ist doch
natürliche Zutaten ich bin ein bisschen
hin und hergerissen was das Thema angeht
denn ich habe den OMR Podcast mit Pamela
reif gehört und ich finde sie schon
sympathisch und wie Sie so Ihr Business
aufgebaut hat und einfach auch mega
fleißig ist und ganz ehrlich den Erfolg
zu 100% verdient hat aber die Kritik an
sie ist natürlich berechtigt und bildet
euch eure eigene Meinung lass einfach
all eure Gedanken Wut und Kritik in den
Kommentaren raus und dann ist das sogar
noch gut für den Algorithmus also
win-win für alle WINWIN demnächst nur im
Kino und bevor ich noch 100 mal Pamela
reif sage dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle Kinder hinter
den Bildschirm mitmachen dieses Videos
nicht ge Salat ich versaue die nächste
Generation ich sag's euch ich weiß nicht
genau wie ich den alten Kalender fand
ich weiß es meine Nichte so Reihe mit
der ich den Kalender ausgepackt habe den
gut fand und ich war glaube ich so
unentschlossen aber darum soll es ja
nicht gehen sondern um den in diesem
Jahr
erstmal ein bisschen Orga hier ne der
Kalender kostet 59 €, 99 60 €, ist okay
ich finde es gut sie wird mit einem
Warenwert von 110 €. das ist jetzt nicht
so ein riesenversprechen wie jetzt bei
Barbara Schöneberger oder Daniela
Katzenberger und er hat einen
unschlagbaren Warenwert von
100 Euro man kriegt halt extra Sachen
und wie ich aus euren Kommentaren
gelernt habe weil wahrscheinlich die
Firmen sich auch Plätze einkaufen können
bzw Pamela vielleicht eine bessere
Kondition bekommt für die Produkte und
es gibt sie an ihre Community weiter die
ist so toll die Familie und die drei
werbepunkte erst without Kane sugar
sustainable Kalender packaging also
Pappe und vegan vegan finden wir gut den
laktose ist unser Feind und jetzt meine
Damen und Herren und ganz kurz das
wichtigste ich habe coole neue
Fingernägel Pam und Friends ja Mensch
Shows gibt's dicker ohne Witz die sind
sehr praktisch dicker können mal gut und
gerne 5 € bei Nanu Nana und so kosten ne
finde ich gar nicht mal Geschlecht und
das wertet jedes Geschenk auf
ich habe mich echt wenig mit diesem
Kalender beschäftigt das sind die
Türchen ja also erster Eindruck die
Schachtel ist süß also sind mir aber zu
viele Häuser hier ich finde das Motiv
schön aber irgendwie dann auch nicht ist
mir einfach zu viele Häuser also wenn
man
zum Beispiel Beziehung ist oder noch bei
seinen Eltern lebt dann bekommt man ja
sowas noch aber wenn man Single ist dann
hat man hier richtig das Gefühl dass das
so heimisch und muckelig ist also hat
jemand für mich verpackt
soll ich denn jetzt so aufstellen ich
kann ja nicht die ganze Zeit durch die
Tüten durch die Tüten gehen hey das hat
sie mit Absicht gemacht um
Adventskalender Tester zu verwirren wir
machen nee nee ich kann mir auch hier
meine Arbeitsfläche nee
boah wir das lange mit dem Suchen dauern
das hier wenigstens nach Ding sortiert
ich bin ja blöd ich hole es aus der
Packung raus es ist eigentlich ganz gut
sortiert hier drin meine Recherche habe
ich hier wo ist mein schöner Block und
mein kleines dickes Notizbuch verloren
der muss jetzt mein großes dickes
Notizbuch her oh tiktok Ideen für 2022
hat ja wunderbar funktioniert
Nachrichtenformat auf lustig mit
Greenscreen super und wir starten mit
dem Türchen Nummer eins du die Pamela
die kann mir sonst was über
kokosblütenzucker erzählen aber wenn Sie
das so toll verpackt das verpackt sie
auch natürlich einzelnd jedes Paket das
haben wir hier Chips jetzt verstehe ich
die kritik.io es ist Fairtrade und ich
finde diese Info hier wirkt schon wie
ein Siegel es ist kein offizielles
Siegel aber es wirkt schon wie ein
Qualitätsmerkmal dass da no Kane sugar
drin ist und es hat trotzdem 23 g Zucker
auf 100 Gramm
[Musik]
ja ich weiß auch nicht also die Produkte
von ihr sind ja eigentlich toll ne das
plastikfrei ich verstehe immer noch also
ich habe keine Ahnung wie man etwas wie
Plastik aussehen lassen kann und es ist
kein Plastik sein soll das soll sich
einfach auflösen können das ist mit Zimt
okay
70 %iger Kakao den schmeckt man zum
Produkt ich finde es schmeckt lecker
nicht so ganz doll nach Zimt und ich
mache mir das immer gern in mein Joghurt
und in mein Joghurt mache ich Geschmack
mit monotischen also habe ich ein
bisschen Christian Wolf und ein bisschen
Pamela reif in meinem Joghurt 100 g 2,99
Türchen Nummer zwei
chocolate outbar 20g Zucker ist hier
drin ich will jetzt aber auch nicht die
ganze Zeit auf dieses zuckerthema
eingehen weil ich denke auch dass man ja
ein Snack mit Zucker essen kann man
verurteilt ja auch nicht jeden der ein
Maßregel sich in der Mittagspause rein
pfeift also und hier sind ja auch
gesunde Zutaten drin ne glutenfrei hallo
hier sehr sehr gut
2,29 €. ich kann ehrlich gesagt
vorstellen wie der schmeckt deswegen
werde ich mir jetzt nicht probieren und
ihnen eine verlosungsbox reinpacken
Nummer drei ist groß
bei Daniela Katzenberger waren die
gleichen Chips drin aber aus Hummus und
mit Tomate Basilikum und die waren sehr
lecker
aus linsenmehl die hauen mich jetzt
nicht vom Hocker aber sie sind lecker
ganz schrecklich seitlich
Adventskalender auspacke haben wir
abends meistens immer was zum snacken da
und das ist nicht gut das was rumliegt
ich bin eigentlich so ein Mensch ich
kaufe nur wirklich dann was wenn ich es
auch an dem Tag essen möchte aber nichts
mehr auf Vorrat also kein
Süßigkeitenschrank oder sonst was wir
haben trotzdem einen weil man kriegt
dann was geschenkt oder so einen landest
du an dem Schrank aber eigentlich immer
nur das kaufen was man noch essen möchte
ein Kilo kostet 27,18 3 für 100 Gramm
ich mache 150 obwohl das das ist echt
eine probierpumpe ich will eigentlich
ein Euro machen Nummer vier ich glaube
das wird hier so ein kleiner influencer
Produkte Adventskalender gitschi das ist
auch so ein influencer Produkt der
ersten Stunde es ist Veganer Nagellack
der ist irgendwie Eko friendly und so oh
Design natürlich top ich kann absolut
nichts zur Qualität sagen ich weiß nicht
ob er schnell absplittert oder ob der
super gut ist ich vermute mal das sehr
gut ist weil Influenza die ich mag dafür
Werbung gemacht habe dafür stehe ich mit
meinem Namen das ist so fies ne 17,90 €
wenn man was gutes tun möchte ne und so
so Nagellack benutzen will ist schon
sie Nummer 5 falls ihr diesen
Adventskalender von mir befüllt gewinnt
sorry für diese ganzen ne Nut Clusters
wenn ich das Wort Nut Clusters höre ne
dann denke ich da kurz dran an so Eier
die so ja die habe ich in meinem letzten
Video schon mal ausprobiert ich mache es
jetzt einfach mal auf weil wir müssen es
einfach ja testen die riechen eins zu
eins wie Mister Tom kennt ihr diesen
Mister Tom Riegel dieser gelbe lange den
es immer an diesen zwei Pack gibt genau
der Duft
Erdnüsse Reissirup dunkle Schokolade wir
hatten das passte Inulin weiß nicht was
es ist ich will mir das nicht mit Pamela
verscherzen Leute ich will dass wir uns
irgendwann mal auf irgendeinem Event
kennenlernen ins Gespräch kommen und
dann ja sagt sie sowas wie wollen wir
Freunde sein dann sage ich sorry ich
habe schon eine beste Freundin fängt sie
an zu weinen sage ich okay komm kannst
du ja eine gute Bekannte von mir werden
dann sagt sie okay für den Anfang ist
das in Ordnung
was war das für eine Geschichte 4,99 €.
ich meine jetzt bin ich ein erwachsener
Mensch ich habe eingeregeltes Einkommen
wenn ich mir aber voll Stelle das kostet
so viel wie eine Packung Ben und Jerry's
und wisst ihr wie selten ich mir eine
Packung Ben und Jerry's gegönnt habe als
ich jünger war das waren Highlight wenn
ich mir so ein Ben & Jerry's Eisbecher
gekauft habe aber auch noch heute bei
solchen Preisen überlege ich mir länger
ob ich etwas kaufen es ist Nikolaus und
wir gehen an unseren Stiefel und danach
an den Pamela Reifen Adventskalender und
darin finden wir ein neues Workout nein
Spaß ein absoluter Klassiker aus der
Familie francy proteinbar cinnamon
coffee der hat 12,9 Gramm Zucker es geht
doch nicht die Schnauze mit dem Zucker
Bio nussriegel mit Sonnenblumen Protein
Reis Christ Schokoladen Kaffee und Zimt
okay dann probiere ich das schon mal
nicht kein Koffein für mich weil ich
schwanger bin
Scherz ich bin nicht schwanger aber ich
liebe es wie oft es vermutet wird
entschuldigen sie bitte was kosten sie
oh auch eine Special Edition glaube ich
wieder 29
Nikolaus ist vorbei aber der siebte
steht jetzt vor der Tür und der hat
bestimmt ach so ja das ist kein
nikolauschen aber gut was sollte sie aus
ihren Produkten an Nikolaus reinmachen
ich habe das Gefühl die Leute vergessen
das Nikolaus ist wahrscheinlich ist es
auch niemanden wichtig außer mir aber
trotzdem Nummer 7 oh yes Linus beits
Spekulatius ganz gesunde keine
kalorienpralinen Spaß Datteln es ist
wieder so ein energy Ball den man dann
als Praline verkauft Datteln Cashew
Mandelcreme kokosblütenzucker Mandeln
Gewürze ich sag's euch das wird lecker
ich nehme alles zurück es ist auf jeden
Fall oh oder nehme ich nun Stoll gewürzt
Moment ich muss mal ganz kurz über den
Geschmack nachdenken
ja ist lecker aber ein bisschen doll
gewürzt weil Euro wir nehmen zwei Euro
40 ich finde die gut das ist meine
Finale Antwort
trotzdem sehen sobald ich die Kamera
ausgemacht habe Nummer 8 das wäre doch
gelacht uh die ist without Kane sugar
okay das ist eine
70%ige Schokolade ich verwende 70%ige
nur zum Backen und Kochen da hört bei
mir der etwas auf und jeder der tut dass
das gut schmeckt ihr denkt noch mal über
euer Verhalten nach okay
2,
6 ist soweit das Türchen Nummer 9 das
wichtigste eines jeden Adventskalenders
und jeder adventskalenderhersteller
sollte das wissen ich muss aber mit
meiner Kritik echt aufpassen wenn ich
mal selber ein Adventskalender mache
also entweder der ist perfekt oder ihr
werdet einfach in der Luft zerrissen
Wild Wild
Deodorant oh das war sie nicht an das
könnte explodieren nein ich möchte das
nicht mit meiner ich noch einmal dran
zum Deo Stick ist natürlich auch Peter
toll da muss man nicht so in dieses
Töpfchen weil bei Festen Deo denke ich
immer bei diesem Töpfchen dass ich das
ein bisschen eklig finde in dieses
Töpfchen rein und dann selber so
vielleicht schon an der schwitzigen
Achse da so rum reiben ist jetzt nicht
meine favorite Aktivität ja falls ihr
den kennt schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare rein ne und falls ihr den
nicht kennt schreibt auch in die
Kommentare rein Leute wir müssen den
Algorithmus ein bisschen anfeuern die
Maschinerie die die muss hier noch ein
bisschen laufen okay drei Stück kosten
14 Euro 4,70 €
die pin-produkte sind natürlich das
tollste weil das ist ja ein
Adventskalender aber irgendwie kennt man
die schon und deswegen sind sie ein
bisschen mehr langweilig ich würde nie
langweilig sagen aber ja
clean Protein war guck mal jetzt mal die
Aufsichtsbehörde was kostest du clean
Protein war 2,49 mit Kaffee
Haselnussgeschmack hätte ich jetzt gerne
probiert aber Kaffee dann geht halt bei
mir
nicht mehr für euch übrig nice Nummer 11
ich doch das ist der Influenza Kalender
schlechthin jungglück von Jung Glück
habe ich absolut keine Ahnung ich habe
nur mal gehört wie meine Managerin jung
Glück erwähnt hat dass es so eine Marke
ist Niacinamid Serum ich hätte gerne
Leon von x-skin CARE so auf der
Kurzwahltaste dass ich ihn immer mal
eben anrufen kann sagen kann
Niacinamid Serum ne ist das gut okay
alles klar nie mehr wollte ich nicht
wissen ja na mach's gut ja nee wir
können da auch keine besten Freunde sein
sorry dass ich diesen schlechten Witz
auch noch mal wiederholt habe ist
einfach
keine Duftstoffe keine Parabene kein
mikroplastik keine Silikone Nieren 39
Euro fehlt nur noch gleich eine aber und
makerze für 100er ich gehe jetzt auf die
Seite von X skin care da ist er Vitamin
A plus Nieren
sind gut für unreine Haut feine Linien
und große Poren niacinamide plus
tran-nexen Säure verbessern von Pickel
malen nyazinamide durch acrylalinsäure
pickelbase gerade die rötlichen okay ihr
wisst jetzt noch weniger als vorher also
habe ich mein Bildungsauftrag erfüllt
und wir machen weiter mit Türchen Nummer
das finde ich interessant ne dass die
ihren direkten Konkurrenten aber nicht
wirklich Konkurrenten weil Pamela
Reisprodukte werden auch hier produziert
man könnte ja sagen der Pamela reif
rodrig schmeckt mir richtig gut und dann
probiert man plötzlich den und es so
boah der ist ja noch besser ich mag aber
keine ziemlich probieren hier der kostet
1,90 dann geh mit 190 der ist sogar
günst weniger als der von Pamela Reifen
3 crunchy Protein Bar Cashew Karamell
wir hatten den ja schon mit Kaffee Zimt
und der schmeckt er überhaupt nicht wie
ein Proteinriegel auf 100 Gramm 25 Gramm
Protein
das ist so ein Riegel kurz bevor ich
Sport mache würde ich mit den
reinzimmern über den Geschmack bin ich
wirklich hin und hergerissen er schmeckt
weil das schmeckt dabei schmeckt
irgendwie auch nicht ich glaube weil er
nicht so süß ist der hat 12 g Zucker
aber schmeckt trotzdem nicht so süß sehr
nussig hä ist schon lecker aber nee ich
bin echt hin und hergerissen zwei 29
Nummer 14 habe ich doch hierhin gepackt
in der Nummer 14 befindet sich jeder
eine Backzutat chocolate chips aber
dieses Mal ohne Zimt 299 kosten die ja
und sind gut zum Backen Nummer 15 Pamela
Reifen und das beiseless ja das sind
halt so Salatdressing man muss sagen das
passt es ist ein Salatdressing das
weißes hat hier anscheinend keine Dings
gegönnt sondern drei Tüten doch das
gehört so 1,50 € 16 bar okay hier bin
ich jetzt doch gespannt also
Erdnussbutter und Schokoladenüberzug aus
Datteln dunkle Schokolade
Zucker nein doch aha da kann man da
Erdnussbutter Erdnüsse wie bei der
Praline ist dieser Riegel komplett mit
Schokolade überzogen das ist gesund
der Nachgeschmack der erste Geschmack
top Nachgeschmack
aber schon deutlich besser als viele
Proteinriegel so sind und ich probiert
habe okay ähm safety first plötzlich
sind hier zwei Sticker
haferharz und at dispoint ne die hätten
also wenn ich das so sehe die hätten das
in Riegel weil keine Ahnung haferriegel
haferotes Adventskalender nennen können
das wiederholt sich echt oft ist halt
ein kleiner Snack den kann man sich gut
mitnehmen Zahn versuchen gesund ich
mache 2 € bei eurem Kopf für 2 €
verkaufe ich dir von dem komm nehme ich
bin so gut heute 18 grandola und da
haben wir schon wieder was mit Hafer
crunchy chocolate Kilopreis sind 20 € 1
für 50g Nummer 19 kein hafer ist drin
meine Damen und Herren kein Hafer was
bist du denn
dark chocolate Mandeln mit Schokolade
Haselnüssen und Erdnüssen
nussriegel mit Schokoladenüberzug das
ist aber eine Süßigkeit ne 2 Euro nehme
ich unser Kalender ist in den 20ern
angekommen und wir kriegen den dritten
nussriegel mit Schokolade crunchy
proteinbar ich glaube der war bei 29
29 Mensch ich kenne bald die Preise von
Pamela Reifs Sortiment auswendig bitte
unser Kalender darf nun in Amerika
Alkohol trinken wir sind bei der Tür 21
und wir haben einen Quinoa bei
und gerne wiegen breakfast Brown ich
weiß wieder schmeckt der schmeckt nach
zusammengequetschten Datteln und ein
bisschen Schokogeschmack und es ist
bestimmt voll lecker und für mich ist
wichtig gesundes Essen frisches Essen
weil es gesundes die kostet 1,99
dann nehmen wir unser nächstes Türchen
Nummer 22
wen haben wir denn da in deutschlandweit
ein Adventskalendern vertreten der
Cookie Kit Cookie Cashew Android das ist
ein Haferflocken Adventskalender hat
jemand geschrieben dass ich ständig den
Inhalt von anderen Kalendern verrate den
sie sich dann gekauft haben also muss
ich in Zukunft ein bisschen aufpassen
also den Gast bei Daniela Katzenberger
das war mein letzter also ab jetzt sage
ich nichts mehr ich mache nur so Morse
code mit den anderen Zuschauern dass Sie
wissen
ja von Daniela Katzenberger
150 ich lese die ganze Zeit 250 29 150
hier geht über die ladenticketsack das
vorletzte Türchen ein clean proteinbar
Brownie ich muss aufhören zu sehen es
tut mir leid
2,49 und meine Damen und Herren es ist
das 24 Türchen es ist Weihnachten wir
gehen aus unserem muckligen Bett raus
draußen schneit es man kommt gar nicht
mehr weg denn alles ist so zugeschneit
also das war's mal vielleicht so ein von
40 Jahren an Heiligabend und dann
stapfen wir mit unseren Füßen die Treppe
runter weil in jedem white American Film
muss man dann im großen herausnehmen und
das ist eine Treppe und dann gehen wir
an unser Adventskalender und machen das
letzte Türchen auf ach nee Spaß wir
kommen gerade vom Joggen und im 24
Türchen befindet sich
ein Glas
wisst ihr warum ich das erinnert an
diese an diese Clowns die irgendwas so
rausziehen hier im 24 Türchen finden wir
die Infos zu jedem Türchen was wir bis
jetzt aufgemacht haben
was haben wir hier crunchy Nussbutter
karamized Allmend ich mache so viele
verschiedene Kalenderwoche habe ich das
Gefühl ständig die gleichen Sachen in
der Hand zu haben ach ich glaube das ist
ihr neues Produkt was oh und ich nutze
meine Reichweite um die ganze
Überraschung schon vor Weihnachten zu
zerstören
es tut mir leid
schmeckt ein bisschen wie gebrannte
Mandeln so ganz bisschen und da sind
geröstete Mandeln drin
kokosblütenzucker karamellisierte
Mandeln und die karamellisierten Mandeln
bestehen aus Mandeln und
kokosblütenzucker und kokosblütensirup
und Meersalz und dann ist auch noch mal
mehr Salz drin ist lecker der für so ein
Frühstück das ist natürlich toll so ein
Glas das einzige was ich mich fragt ne
mal gucken ob ihr wisst was ich meine
das Schild naturally Pam das sieht aus
als ob das zu einer zu kleine
PNG Datei wäre die man zu groß gezogen
hat und dann ist die nicht so richtig
scharf gedruckt im Vergleich aber
worüber reden wir gerade ne ich gebe der
Nussbutter 5 €, ich schätze irgendwie
dass sie so viel kosten wird sobald sie
erhältlich ist die Hälfte sind auf jeden
Fall Riegel dann haben wir noch so ein
Gewürz
Nussbutter zweimal chocolate chips und
Dings und Granola wir gucken uns mal den
Preis an Sie haben nicht gelogen als sie
gesagt haben ein Warenwert von über 110
€
112,36 € und damit hat man richtig was
bekommen für sein Geld was ist nun mein
Fazit für diesen Adventskalender also
die Geschmacksrichtungen wiederholen
sich ein bisschen das finde ich schade
also man hat auch das Gefühl
Schokolade kokosblumen Zucker Datteln
Dings also das wechselt sich immer so
gerne ab und dann kommen irgendwelche
Nüsse noch dazu und dann haben wir schon
wieder was neues vielleicht hätten mehr
Beauty Produkte reingekonnt damit sich
das irgendwie mehr vermischt aber man
kann sagen was man will der Preis ist 60
€ man bekommt etwas für über 110 € und
dann ist es noch so verpackt ne die
Auswahl der Dinger finde ich jetzt nicht
optimal aber ja superkalender und was
sie sich da auf tik streiten damit habe
ich nichts zu tun da halte ich mich raus
dann nehme ich Abstand von bis zum
nächsten Mal ich gehe jetzt trainieren
weil ich zu spät Energie habe durch
kokosblütenzucker ich weiß wirklich
nicht was heute mit mir los ist falls
ihr das erste Mal mich jetzt gerade
gesehen habe zum bin ich wirklich nicht
immer